so Tuesday I told you that Republicans
finally have themselves a voter fraud
scandal on their hands but really it's
an election fraud scandal and this is
all out of North Carolina's ninth
district this was a congressional race
in the 2018 midterms which we had at
this point about about actually I think
it's been a month
to the day where Republican Mark Harris
supposedly defeated Democratic opponent
Dan McReady by nine hundred and five
votes out of 280,000 cast and we had
reports of people being paid to pick up
absentee ballots in person illegal
reportedly handing them off to a known
Republican operative also illegal and
then we had a whole bunch of other
little issues reported little compared
to that one but still significant issues
problems at the polls unrequested
absentee ballots arriving at people's
houses really major red flags about the
integrity of this election we now have
more news more than a thousand absentee
ballots have been potentially destroyed
thousands remember the race came down to
905 votes in favor of the Republican we
still don't know exactly what is even
being alleged here because there are
many moving parts I mentioned on Tuesday
that a ton of absentee ballots had
witness signatures from the same group
of people which is really strange why is
there a group of people involved as
signing off as witnesses for so many
people's mailed and absentee ballots
didn't really make sense we haven't
gotten an explanation
so what investigators are now looking at
are basically two two different areas of
investigation one have people connected
to this Republican activist Leslie
McCray Dallas who consulted for the
Republican candidate in the race were
they gathering unsealed absentee ballots
marking them for the Republican and then
signing them as witnesses that would be
unconscionable election fraud and it's
one explanation for why they're going
around
asking for people's absentee ballots
that they haven't sent in that's one
possibility
we now also have the destruction of
absentee ballots component and that
would suggest a different strategy which
is showing up pretending to be election
officials to collect absentee ballots
from voters in democratic areas and then
destroying them ripping them up throwing
them in the trash instead of turning
them in House Democrats are looking for
an emergency hearing unclear if they're
going to get it at this point but my
concern Pat is that this story needs a
lot more attention there is fraud
happening it's not people voting twice
it's not people showing up and giving
the names of dead people it's not
illegal immigrants from Massachusetts
getting on buses and going up to New
Hampshire to vote for Hillary Clinton
it's this Republican suppression of the
vote and it's not getting the attention
that it deserves well the good news is
that the election hasn't yet been
certified but the new Congress the 116th
Congress that's set to take place in a
few weeks and I'm worried that there's
going to be this rush to get it all done
and I hope there is a thorough
investigation into all of this I hope
they don't they don't just figure well
the Republicans up by 905 votes and
North Carolina's ninth needs a needs a
representative so we have to make sure
he's offered in right away
now let's slow it down make sure that we
understand who actually won this
election we're talking about thousands
of possibly destroyed ballots when the
margin of victory was 905 its Republican
suppression of the vote they are
straight up trying to steal an election
and they might get away with it there's
by the way an entire additional story
here which I haven't even gotten to
which is that some of the same patterns
that we saw in the general election in
the North Carolina ninth seem to have
existed in the primary Republican Mark
Harris which implies although it's not
yet proven that he did the exact same
thing in the Republican primary people
actually need to end up in prison here
if any of this is proven today's program
was made possible in part by Blink
esteem / Pakman I love bling cast it's
the really perfect
app for anybody who likes politics and
learning and if you're watching or
listening to the David Pakman show I'm
sure you love politics and learning and
what blinka studs is take the best and
most popular non-fiction books they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to in one sitting
and you can learn about politics
philosophy psychology economics often we
don't have the time to actually read as
many books as we would like I know that
I'm at my limit for how much I can read
and this way you can absorb the most
important valuable information from
books in just 15 minutes maybe on your
way to work maybe on your way to the gym
maybe cooking vegan recipes at home
whatever is your thing and our audience
can get a seven day free trial by going
to blink accom slash Pakman if you're
watching on YouTube I've put a link in
the video description and after the free
trial if you like it and I think you
will you can continue enjoying thousands
of condensed audiobooks for just about
five bucks a month you can go to be li
NK is t.com slash PA k ma n to sign up